et allons plus loin dans l'entretien ce
soir avec nous gaël giraud bienvenue
vous êtes économiste directeur de chez
de recherche au cnrs et vous avez été
chef économiste pour l'agencé française
du développement merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation
vous avez d'ailleurs été auditionné il
ya peu au sénat sur la manière de sortir
de la crise
le sénat qui vient de faire 50
propositions on n'a pas tous exactement
mais on a cet acte de décentralisation
très fort est ce que pour vous c'est un
bon axe oui je pense que la pandémie est
disons les cafouillages incroyable qui a
eu lieu dans différents organes
administratifs de la france ne fût ce
que pour avoir des masques pour avoir
des enzymes pour faire du dépistage a
montré en fait à montrer que le roi
était nu en matière de décentralisation
et je pense que c'est très heureux qu'on
puisse avoir aujourd'hui un vrai débat
parce qu'en réalité depuis trente ans on
a abandonné le thème de la
décentralisation et il faut la repenser
entièrement je crois alors cela dit dans
ce qu'on vient d'entendre il ya deux
points à mon avis il faut souligner le
premier c'est ne plus mettre l'hôpital
au centre du dispositif sanitaire
français je pense que ça c'est une très
bonne idée celui qu'il faut mettre au
centre c'est le médecin généraliste qui
le premier contact avec le patient et
qui réoriente le patient éventuellement
vers l'hôpital mais pas nécessairement
vers l'hôpital est donc là il ya une
revalorisation du métier de médecin
généraliste à mettre en oeuvre le
passage pour les aides soignantes à
devenir infirmière je pense une très
bonne idée j'ai été aide soignant
moi-même pendant un mois et demi donc je
sais ce que c'est et c'est vrai qu'il ya
plein de situations dans les actes dans
lesquelles les aides soignants pose déjà
des actes qui sont très très proches de
ce que fait d'infirmières donc je crois
que ça c'est une très bonne idée alors
en revanche privatiser l'hôpital public
c'est je pense une très très mauvaise
idée c'est à dire que ce dont la
pandémie a fait la démonstration c'est
pas du tout que le secteur public est
inefficace et au contraire quand vous
abandonnez le secteur public qui devient
efficace mais parce qu'on l'a abandonné
et donc il faut certainement pas
privatiser l'obtînt public faut redonner
les moyens à l'hôpital public de remplir
sa mission de service public la logique
du sénat c'est aussi de dire qu'ils
décident paye qui payent qui décident
donner plus de liberté aux localités aux
municipalités aux collectivités c'est
aussi plus leur donner d'argent tout à
fait absolument
il faut responsabiliser les
collectivités territoriales leur donner
les moyens
en fait des compétences qu'on leur a
attribué parce qu'on leur ait deux on
leur a donné des compétences sans moyens
et sans responsabilité
du coup évidemment ils n'ont pas assumé
ses compétences il faut leur redonner
les moyens et aussi la responsabilité de
sorte qu'on sagelat qui se tourne et le
jour où on aura pas de masquer ce qui ne
s'est pas passé ces derniers temps c'est
pas parce macron avait supprimé la taxe
d'habitation qui a complètement
bouleversé les finances des
collectivités ça c'était une très
mauvaise et c'est une très belle maison
raynaud collectivement entre autres oui
tout à fait alors il ya la relance vu
par le sénat et puis il ya la relance qu
emmanuel macron lui veut européenne et
s'est entretenu avec angela merkel lundi
dernier il veut un accord dès ce mois ci
un dès le mois de juillet sur le budget
sur le plan de relance économique nous
sommes arrivés à un moment de vérité
pour l'europe nous dit le président
français
vous pensez que l'europe sera vraiment
au rendez vous de ce moment historique
j'en suis passionné ce que je constate
c'est qu'en guélat merkel sait faire des
concessions l effet in extremis avant
qu'il ne soit trop tard
donc pour la première fois depuis une
trentaine d'années l'allemagne accepte
qu'on puisse avoir de la dette
le communautaire cela dit 750 milliards
sur trois ans donc vous / 3 % le montant
chaque année / 27 ça fait dépouiller m
par pays c'est vraiment tout à fait
insignifiant par rapport à la gravité de
la récession dans laquelle on est en
train d'entrer
donc le niveau est pas du tout le bon
ensuite la question des 750 milliards
c'est vont-ils être fléché vers le vert
s'il s'agit de capitaliser à l'italienne
en italie comme on a recapitalisé air
france klm en france font pas tellement
l'intérêt on est juste en train de
ressusciter le monde hier dont on sait
et tous les travers et puis dernière
puis troisièmement comment est-ce qu'on
va payer cette dette parce que même si
c'est de la dette communautaire c'est la
dette
si on exige le remboursement de cette
dette en augmentant la contribution de
chaque état au budget européen on n'a
rien gagné on a gagné un tout petit peu
parce que l'allemagne par exemple va
contribuer un peu plus que ce qu'elle va
recevoir mais fondamentalement on
n'aurait rien changé
donc il faut lever une nouvelle
ressource fiscale de manière à
rembourser cette dette communautaire et
cette nouvelle ressource fiscale qu'est
ce que ça peut être ça peut être une
taxe carbone aux frontières de la zone
euro ça peut être une taxe sur les
transactions financières depuis le temps
qu'on en parle ça peut être une taxe sur
les gars fun mais il faut absolument
qu'on ait ce débat et de manière
démocratique en europe aujourd'hui
et pourtant beaucoup parle tout de même
d'un plan historique ne serait ce que
parce qu'on a changé de logiciel et que
c'est peut-être ça la révolution la mini
révolution qui est en train de se
produire en europe vous n'êtes pas
d'accord je suis pas sûr je demande à
voir si vous voulez il faut faire
attention à la distance qui peut séparer
des grands discours et les belles
paroles des actes effectivement mis en
oeuvre
donc j'ai l'impression que depuis
quelques années on est trop habitués y
compris en france
à se fier aux paroles et aux vents et
aux beaux discours qui vous annoncent la
fin du capitalisme le changement radical
de société et les actes qui sont posés
sont pas du tout en accord avec les
paroles qui sont prononcés je prends un
exemple le discours du président de la
république sur la convention citoyenne
bas la convention citoyenne à mon avis
est un extraordinaire exploit qui a été
réalisé par nos 150 citoyens tirés au
hasard qui se sont formés pendant neuf
mois qui ont accouché d'un texte
absolument magnifique je pense pas du
tout que l'élysée s'attendait à un tel
travail d'une telle qualité
donc maintenant on est d'élise est au
pied du mur donc du président de la
république à juste titre accueille les
propositions et dit c'est très bien on
va aller dans cette direction là mais
propose 15 milliards de dépenses
budgétaires supplémentaires pour
financer ce que propose la convention
alors ce n est pas du tout à l'échelle
c'est ridicule ridicule on n'est pas du
tout mon temps alors combien il faudrait
ça dépend de la manière dont vous faites
les calculs mais disons
fran stratégie et l'ademe chacune
séparément arrive à quelque chose comme
50 milliards donc on n'est pas du tout
on n'est pas du tout à l'échelle donc si
vous voulez promettre on va mettre en
oeuvre la convention citoyenne mais ne
pas aligner le budget nécessaire pour le
financer c'est juste dire on n'a pas le
faire on reviendra sur les propositions
de la convention citoyenne jours et
qu'on reste encore un tout petit peu sur
l'europe
voilà ce qu'a dit emmanuel macron alors
vous me direz ce sont des mots sont ses
paroles mais les voici
il me semble essentiel que l'argent
qu'apportera l'europe aux pays qui font
leur transition écologique soit
strictement conditionné à des
engagements climatiques précis à
commencer par la neutralité carbone en
2050 c'est une demande forte ça veut
dire qu emmanuel macron a compris que
s'il relance européenne il doit y avoir
elle doit forcément être tournées vers
l'environnement
mais ça c'est pour pour vous c'est fort
ah ça c'est extraordinaire ça s'est très
très bien
et donc si on le met en oeuvre je serai
ravi mais la france elle-même viole les
accords de paris de 2015 depuis cinq ans
la france elle même ne tient pas ses
engagements de réduction des émissions
de co2 pour atteindre la neutralité
carbone en 2050 donc c'est très bien
qu'on s'y engage mais on va porter les
conséquences de l'engagement qu'on vient
de prononcer mais ce qu'on peut avec
tous ces principes écologiques
environnementaux et aussi sociaux
rivaliser avec par exemple une chine qui
n'a pas du tout les mêmes scrupules les
mêmes états d'âme alors ça c'est une
très bonne question vous avez raison de
la pose et je pense qu'il va falloir
qu'un jour ou l'autre on brise le tabou
du protectionnisme et qu'on se dise mais
au fond qu'est ce que le libre-échange
tous azimuts à apporter vraiment à
l'occident et c'est pas clair du tout
avec les estimations macroéconomie qui
ont été faites pour essayer d'estimer
combien ça nous a rapporté en gros la
globalisation marchande financiarisé
depuis une trentaine d'années
aboutissent au mieux dans le meilleur
des cas à quelques centaines de
milliards de dollars ce qui est ridicule
le pig mondial c'est 70 mille milliards
dans quelques centaines c'est vraiment
des miettes et en plus qui plus est
essentiellement au bénéfice de la chine
donc il faut s'interroger qu'est ce que
le protectionnisme nous a apporté en
fait pour les françaises et les français
aujourd'hui pas grand chose parce que
c'est pas vrai que les très bas salaires
chinois se sont répercutées sur les très
bas prix avec lesquels on a pu acheter
des gadgets vous envoie les finir nous
parce qu'entre temps les ceux qui ont
fait la distribution le 10 ans la
transmission la médiation entre la chine
et la france ont fait des marges
colossales colossal et donc en réalité
le prix n'a pas beaucoup augmenté
et comme nous autres on sait pas à
combien pour quel prix on travaillait
travailleur chinois on se rend pas
compte du tout la marche colossal qui a
été réalisé par les intérêts
l'intermédiation donc en réalité la très
faible valeur des salaires chinois n'a
pas été répercutée dans les prix
donc nous n'avons pas été les
bénéficiaires en premier lieu de cette
globalisation marchande et du coup ce
que ça veut dire c'est que si on
relocalise est aujourd'hui des
entreprises qui sont délocalisés en
chine
ça n'est pas vrai non plus qu'on aurait
une explosion des prix à condition d'en
pêcher des intermédiaires de continuer
d'avoir des marges colossales
c'est ça les rentes alors je me souviens
par exemple du fait que présente la
république anti tard ils vont pouvoir a
dit moi mon programme c'est à dire
produire matelly c'est de supprimer les
rendre dans ce pays pour être plus
efficace très bien mais là on a des
rentes extraordinaires qui sont
accumulées depuis une trentaine d'années
cc rentre là qu'il faut supprimer
et pour le faire il faut relocaliser et
on peut très bien localisés et organiser
un protectionnisme social sanitaire
écologique intelligente je parlais de
difficultés pour l'europe à s'affirmer
face à des puissances comme la chine
avec justement ces scrupules
environnementaux et sociaux qui sont
presque devenu un handicap
est-ce qu après tout tant pis est-ce que
c'est pas à l'europe aussi de montrer
une sorte de chemin presqu'un justement
le monde d'après tout à fait vous avez
un rôle si c'est absolument notre rôle
je peux vous dire par expérience comme
chef économiste de l'afd agence
française de développement que le monde
entier regarde ce que fait l'europe
l'amérique latine a les yeux rivés sur
l'europe parce que nous restons malgré
tout malgré tous nos défauts un modèle
extraordinaire pour toute une série de
pays qui sont en étude et qui regarde ce
que nous faisons en particulier de la
france pour toute une série de pays nous
restons la patrie des droits de l'homme
aujourd'hui même si de temps en temps
nous avons nous mêmes les droits de
l'homme ce qu'est ce qui est pas de la
sq ont tergiversé parce qu'on discute
parce qu'on débat aussi au sein de notre
pays mais on montre un chemin vous dit
qu'elle était alors à l'international
tout le monde nous regarde et nous
aurions une valeur d'exemplarité
extraordinaire si nous prenions enfin en
main notre destinée collective pour
mettre en oeuvre la re construction
écologique du pays ça voudrait que
peut-être une fois que nous aurons réglé
nos propres discussions et
tergiversations le monde suivra que
finalement alors là vous le secteur
culturel d'abord on n'aurait jamais
terminé nos discussions
ça fait partie de l'espace démocratique
qu'on continue de délibérer en
permanence un simplement il faut agir en
délibérant par exemple je donne un
exemple à en 2014 on a mis en place
le comité des experts pour un débat
national sur la transition sous l'égide
de delphine batho les experts dont j'ai
fait partie on dressait une famille une
liste quatre grandes familles le
scénario transition énergétique pour la
france alors d'une certaine manière le
grand débat qui est devant nous
aujourd'hui c'est lequel lequel les
quatre scénario négawatt négatif en cas
hatem ce qui les distingue c'est en gros
le bouquet énergétique français en 2035
et pour simplifier la part du nucléaire
dans le bouquet énergétique français
on sait que ça c'est le truc sur
lesquels nous adorons nous les français
nous bagarrer en permanence c'est la
faire revivre telle affaire dreyfus du
début du xxième siècle
mais en fait il ya des tas de choses
qu'on pourrait faire tout de suite sans
même avoir réglé cette question du
nucléaire en france
on pourrait faire la rénovation
thermique des bâtiments tout de suite en
particulier la rénovation thermique des
bâtiments publics
rien ne fait obstacle au fait que nous
fassions dès maintenant et ceci depuis
dix ans déjà
on pourrait engager un vrai programme de
réaménagement du territoire pour faire
l'optimisation urbaine pour faire la
police agriculture autour des centres
urbains très dense reliés entre eux par
du train donc il faut réhabiliter par
exemple la sncf et le réseau de chemin
de fer extrêmement dense que nous avions
après 1945
tout ça on peut le faire sans même se
prononcer immédiatement sur la question
du nucléaire
et pourquoi ne le faisons pas à ça c'est
une grande question il manque la volonté
politique juste la volonté politique ou
aussi peut-être financement non le mode
de financement on a mis 300 milliards
d'euros de garanties publiques
aujourd'hui il y en a que 100 milliards
qui ont été appelés à ma connaissance
jusqu'à présent il en reste deux sens
avec les deux sens on peut très très
facilement financer par exemple la
rénovation thermique des bâtiments
publics en france
et qu'est ce que ça a comme conséquence
vous réhabiliter les centres villes de
toutes nos villes moyennes qui sont
complètement dégradés vous diminuer
notre dépendance au pétrole
vous améliorez la balance commerciale et
vous crée énormément d'emplois
vous créez en main en moyenne 15 emplois
par millions d'euros investis et donc
comme ça doit vous coûter quelque chose
comme 6 2 7 6 7 milliards par an sur
deux trois ans vous créer au moins cinq
cent mille emplois voire un million
d'emplois sur trois ans ce qui est
colossal
si on revient sur les pardons si on
revient sur les propositions de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat
emmanuel macron écarté la taxe de 4 %
sur les dividendes pour les
investissements dans le vert dans
l'écologie vous dit qu'il a fait une
erreur oui il a fait une erreur je pense
que les
si vous voulez c'est un problème de fond
depuis une quarantaine d'années à la
globalisation marchande et le
capitalisme financiarisé dans lequel
nous sommes entrés en réalité a rompu
les amarres avec le capitalisme tout
court au sens où nous avons donné tous
les pouvoirs à des grands corps
d'actionnaires par exemple les fonds
communs de placement qui n'épouse
absolument pas la logique des
entreprises dans lesquelles ils
investissent qui sont simplement en
attente n'a rendement sur actions quoi
qu'il arrive alors il se peut que
l'entreprise ait des soucis qui sont
tout à fait légitimes par exemple ce que
la conjoncture est pas bonne alors ces
grands groupes d'actionnaires s'en fiche
complètement et exige quoi qu'il arrive
du 10 % de rendement sur l'action par an
dans une économie qui a pas de
croissance c'est juste impossible donc
ça oblige les entreprises à faire des
opérations qui sont qui n'ont absolument
aucun sens d'un point de vue économique
par exemple elle s'endette pour racheter
leurs propres actions sur le marché
actions et faire des cadeaux à leurs
actionnaires
oui mais quand on fait ça ça n'a plus
aucune aucune relation avec la logique
du business réelle de l'entreprise dans
l'économie réelle est donc cet
actionnariat la tue le capitalisme en
vérité et donc il ya un moment où il
faut la raisonner et se dire mais nous
on veut protéger nos entreprises en
particulier en france on veut protéger
au fait même le capitalisme 10 à 30 ans
a besoin d'être protégé et pour ça il
faut mettre des barrières à lui brice de
cet actionnariat
alors si on refuse de taxer les
dividendes on est juste en train de
donner le signal que ça va continuer et
être noël tous les jours pour cet
actionnariat
et pourtant ils manière là qu'on nous
dit que justement ça ne sonne freinera
pas les investissements on a besoin des
investissements ils essayent de
réconcilier économie de marché et
écologie ce qui sur le papier paraît un
peu un compatissez vrai on a besoin
absolument d'investissement que je suis
d'accord avec vous et on est en sous
investissement depuis une vingtaine
d'années en particulier en france
investissements publics et privés la
grande difficulté c'est que l'obstacle
majeur à l'investissement privé en
france aujourd'hui c'est pas le fait que
l'on n'ait pas fait suffisamment de
cadeaux aux actionnaires on a fait
tellement dans l'obstacle majeur c'est
le surendettement privé
alors on parle beaucoup dans les médias
du surendettement public il n'a pas
complètement tort c'est vrai que l'on a
beaucoup de dettes publiques mais la
dette privée c'est beaucoup plus grave
que la dette publique et en plus elle
est beaucoup plus importante que la
dette publique avant la pandémie
on était à 99 % du pipe de dettes
publiques bon on va passer à 120 à peu
près
mais en dette privée on était à 130
avant la pandémie alors je ne sais pas
combien on va passer peut-être 150
aujourd'hui mais ça veut dire qu'on est
beaucoup plus endettés dans le secteur
privé que dans le secteur public
or quand vous avez un état qui a
beaucoup de dettes c'est compliqué il
peut continuer d'investir en fait il
n'est pas mort le japon à 250 % du pibe
de dette publique les japonais sont pas
morts en revanche une entreprise qui a
trop de dette
d'abord n'arrivent plus à rembourser ses
dettes est certainement ne peut plus
investir ce qu'aucune banque ne prête à
lui prêter pour qu'elles investissent et
donc la fin d'investissement en europe
depuis une vingtaine d'années c'est pas
qu'on n'a pas été assez sympa avec les
actionnaires
c'est qu'on n'arrive pas à résoudre le
problème du surendettement privé de nos
entreprises du coup j'ai un termina sur
ma démonstration l'urgence des urgences
aujourd'hui pour sortir de la déflation
dans la zone euro s'est pas d'obliger
les états se désendetter coûte que coûte
c'est pas l'austérité budgétaire qui ne
résoudra rien en terme de dette publique
si vous regardez la grèce on a infligé
une cure d'austérité budgétaire
incroyable à la grèce en cinq ans on a
diminué le pipe de 25 pour ça on a dix
minutes où les salaires de 25% en tout
cas mais le ratio dette publique sur pib
en grèce est le même aujourd'hui qu'en
2010 au début de la crise de la dette
publique grecque 180 pour ça ça n'a rien
changé donc l'austérité budgétaire ne
résout rien sur la dette publique
donc c'est surtout pas ça qu'il faut
faire il faut au contraire que l'état
continue d'investir pendant que le
secteur privé se désendette c'est ça
l'urgence c'est une désendetter le
secteur privé deleverage et quand on dit
dans le fond
l'anglais des marchés une fois que le
secteur privé s'est désendetté il peut
monter à bord du projet du grand projet
de reconstruction écologique de la
france
et à ce moment là l'état se retire et
lui se désendette après coup mais voyez
c'est dans cet endroit là qu'il faut le
faire en exigeant que l'état se
désendette d'abord on est en train de
mettre la charrue avant les boeufs et ça
ça marche pas et là on est en train de
s'enfoncer dans la déflation et le japon
lui il est tombé dans la déflation et à
25 ans il arrive toujours pas en sortir
et moi c'est ce que je crains pour la
pour l'europe aujourd'hui c'est que
l'austérité budgétaire qui a l'air
d'être une espèce de mesures de bon sens
pierre moscovici l'a rappelé quand on a
des dettes on paie ses lettres je suis
d'accord avec ça sauf que quand ça nous
fait mourir
il vaut mieux ne pas payer c'est d'être
tout de suite au mieux reporter à plus
tard le moment de payer ses dettes
pour continuer d'investir dans le grand
plan de la reconstruction écologique
appelée de ses voeux par la convention
de citoyennes et ensuite une fois que le
privé pourra monter à bord
l'état se défend d'être un on va sortir
des questions économiques va reprendre
un petit peu de hauteur vous êtes aussi
prêtre jésuite peut-être que peu de gens
le savent je voudrais ton votre regard
spirituelle sur ce que nous vivons ce
que c'est quand même assez particulier
ce qu'on vient de vivre ce virus
microscopiques qui terrasse la planète
pour vous c'est une leçon pour l'être
humain qui tue danois est tout petit et
a tendance à l'oublier c'est vrai je
pense que c'est une grande leçon
spirituel un qui a été en partie tiré
d'ailleurs par le père françois dans les
différentes allocutions publiques qu'il
a donné pendant la pandémie mais qui au
fond était déjà écrit dans la hotte date
aussi la grande encyclique de 2015 sur
l'écologie c'est à dire ceux dont nous
avons fait l'expérience et que nous
détruisons les écoumène naturels dans
lesquels nous vivons ce qui nous
rapproche d'un certain nombre d'animaux
qui sont porteurs de virus face
auxquelles nous n'avons aucune
immunologie typiquement la chauve souris
qui est porteur de tous les coronavirus
alors il ya un animal de médiation donc
le pangolin et précédemment c'était la
civette palmer et c'est bon mais en
réalité ce qui se passe et qu'on se
rapproche de plus en plus d'animaux que
nous ne connaissons pas et ça pourquoi
parce que nous par exemple nous
pratiquons la déforestation de manière
systématique ou nous détruisons nous et
que nous et qui mène ce qui nous
rapproche finalement donc ça c'est si
vous voulez l'hubris d'une humanité qui
n'acceptent pas que l puisse avoir en
face d'elle une nature une création d'un
langage chrétien qui lui parler à qui
elle peut parler et dont elles doivent
prendre soin ça c'est une brive et même
peut-être supérieur
non j'ai pas dit ça kiki et son alter
ego et son interlocutrice
c'est à dire il faut rompre avec une
anthropologie si vous laissez
l'anthropologie de l'homme de vitruve de
léonard de vinci
oui cet homme qui est comme ça dans un
temps un triangle est un cercle
cet homme là d'abord c'est un homme mal
y'a pas de femmes il est dans une
solitude métaphysique total il connaît
pas les femmes comme représentation
l'humanité oui il ya cody les blancs les
autres peuples de la planète n'existe
pas il n'y a pas d'enfant
y'a pas de vieillards n'y a pas de
malade donc il est en bonne santé et des
adultes et la nature n'est pas là donc
ni dans une solitude métaphysique
absolue et qu'est ce qui lui reste comme
support la géométrie dans son triangle
son cercle et la toute puissance de la
science le contrôle en tout cas
contrôler la maîtrise
voilà et donc c'est cette anthropologie
la la solitude métaphysique de l'homme
mâle blanc
le quart no fun logo centrisme ça c'est
un terme de jacques derrida carnot il
mange de la viande et vous aurez
remarqué que c'est en général les mecs
qui ont du mal à arrêter de manger de
l'avion alors qu'il faudrait du point de
vue écologique
fall logo parce que dans fallujah
phallus donc c'est la phallocratie et
logo parce que c'est cette supériorité
prétendu des européens à cause de logos
grecque qui les rendraient des seuls
apôtre de civils et de la rationalité
universel à ce qu il pas vrai donc le
quart no fun logo centrisme européen
c'est ça dont il faut se déprendre
aujourd'hui c'est ça dont il faut sortir
et le virus lui comme d'un virus nous
montre qu'en réalité nous sommes une
fragilité
un signe que nous dépendons des échos
mais naturelle avec lesquelles nous
vivons et que la création est une vraie
interlocutrice qui nous parle et nous
parle à travers ce virus est au fond si
vous réfléchissez minutes elle nous a
parlé de manière très bienveillante
parce que nous allons nous rendre compte
malheureusement dans quelques mois
sauf s'il y avait une grande deuxième
vague terrible cet automne mais que
finalement le virus aura tué beaucoup
moins que le confinement
c'est à dire la très mauvaise réponse
que nous avons apportées à la pandémie
et que certains pays ont réussi à éviter
taiwan la corée du sud le vietnam qui
est quand même pas un pays très
développé
la thaïlande ont échappé complètement au
confinement et dans ce monde après que
vous qu'on commence à observer qu on est
peut-être en train de vivre est ce que
vous sentez une remise en question de
l'homme de son arrogance de son
sentiment de supériorité de surpuissance
est ce que vous vous hanter qu'on ait un
virage un tournant ou est ce qu'en fait
on est déjà tombé dans les anciens
travers et que la crise n'aura pas servi
à nous améliorer nous non je crois pas
je crois que du côté on pourrait dire il
ya il ya deux france qui ont vécu le
confinement et à la france pour
caricaturer un des csp + qui a plutôt
apprécié le télétravail qui s'est rendu
compte qu'il pouvait très bien travaillé
chez elle en particulier dans sa maison
de campagne dans le vexin par exemple et
qui en fait t'as plus envie de retourner
au bureau aujourd'hui et qui se verrait
bien travailler en province dans un
atelier à un ensemble un espace de cours
ne colorent king
et puis vous avez des autres qui ont
souffert terriblement pendant
confinement certains sont allés bosser
sans masque sans gel ont pris des
risques pour les autres français
donc pour eux le confinement ce n'est
pas du tout une partie de plaisir et
cela c'est pas l'écologie qui est venu
en tête c'est pas la remise en cause de
cette anthropologie là
je décrivais un instant qui devient
première pour cette partie là de la
france c'est là sur rio la survie la
sécurité d'emploi la sécurité tout court
dit non et donc il faut pas se tromper
il faut pas se tromper
là les csp + se sont radicalisées du
côté de l'écologie est certainement sont
en train en ce moment de sortir de cette
vision d'anthropologie anthropologique
de l'homme de vitruve de léonard de
vinci
pour ceux qui étaient encore habité par
sa typiquement l'homme éduquer mal
urbain centre-ville bon mais le reste de
la population et dans une problématique
complètement différent mais on est dans
une situation complètement
schizophrénique vous rendez compte de la
complexité du message à interpréter pour
pour nos responsables politiques puisque
c'est à eux d'agir pour les mois qui les
années qui vont suivre
quel est le message qu il doit revenir
de cette crise à mon avis le message
c'est que la réponse à la question
sociale c'est l'écologie
l'écologie n'est pas une contrainte de
plus écologique
la construction écologique écologique
créé plus d'emplois que le monde d'avant
je donne un exemple simple dans le monde
d'avant les chiffres que nous avons sur
l'emploi ne sont pas sont pas exacts
pourquoi parce que ils ne tiennent pas
compte du travail partiel travail à
temps partiel si vous tenez compte du
travail à temps partiel nous avions ce
30 % de chômage avant la pandémie et
nous allons avoir beaucoup plus après la
pandémie donc en réalité le monde
d'avant était incapable de fournir du
travail et tout le monde absolument
incapable ressusciter le monde d'avant
ne résoudra aucun des problèmes sociaux
que nous avons aujourd'hui
en revanche la re construction
écologique ça crée des emplois ça donne
du sens à votre boulot donc vous sortez
des bullshit job au 102 gréber qui
rendent malade tout le monde est
évidemment ça ne peut se faire que si
vous accompagner par la formation
professionnelle ceux qui aujourd'hui
sont coincés dans les secteurs condamné
l'aéronautique avec le kérosène la
voiture à la thermique à pétrole ou 90
donc ces gens là il faut les accompagner
vers des métiers qui ont du sens et qui
dessine la société que nous voulons une
france zéro carbone en 2050 et c'était
peut-être un message à emmanuel macron
qui est en plein en pleine spéculation
pour un rêve un remaniement merci
infiniment tout cas gaël giraud d'avoir
fait cet entretien avec nous